when I had finished my own sentence
period and I got sentenced to nine and a
half years because I hadn't cooperated
with the prosecutor she done a number of
tricks on me throughout my remand like
stopping my girl from visiting me but a
final farewell was she accidentally put
my 9 and a half year sentence down as 34
years so I was fast-tracked to Supermax
then for about three or four months
where was it supposed to be until they
fixed that after that I got sentenced to
medium security hoping that they would
be softer than you know Supermax and
these other places have come from max in
the jail why I end up in a cell with a
serial home invader torturing this guy
was breaking into people's houses tying
him up with duct tape and taking hammers
to their kneecaps and he's welcome
statements of me I've got a padlock in a
sock because smashy brains him obviously
can kill you and everyone so II didn't
like me from the get-go he was an old
con he looked at me as a fresh fish he
just was running a tattoo shop illegal
tattoo shop out the cell and just you
know doing the heroin all day and I mean
no you know I've got an education bit of
a nerdy guy so he didn't he didn't like
that at all so he got his mate who was a
huge guy to attack me when my parents
have flown 5,000 miles to visit me for
Christmas prisons like high school
mentality with deadly consequences but
the two things prisoners look forward to
the most are visits and mail so he knew
by spoiling that visit you know that
would be devastating for me so I'm on
the way to the visit regard you
[ __ ] move sneaks up behind me BAM
Bam's that's kidney punch in all the
prisoners stop see my reaction cuz gang
rule is you must hit back or else you're
a punk
everyone's gonna pray on you if you
don't hit back bad consequences with the
prisoners but if you do hit back in the
guard see it then you arrest it sense of
prison have in the prison lockdown lose
all your privileges improving your visit
and they can have more time on to your
sentence if you don't hit back you
become a prison Punk you're gonna spend
the rest of your time inside cleaning
people's toilets performing sexual
services and getting rented that was a
prison prostitute so what do you do in
that situation you gotta throw the kicks
and punches well this guy was so big and
strong it was like hitting a big bag of
cement it didn't end that well for me he
knocked me down smash me up and I ended
up going to the visit all injured now I
didn't manage to get moved out with that
cell and my new cellmate Long Island
he'd come from a prison were his
neighbor it said if you coming into
contact with an English gang with Shawn
he's a good dude I did business with him
on the streets this is guy called
gangster Dan from Philadelphia yeah like
he's thumb missing and [ __ ] so Long
Island ends up my cellmate and the
chances of that I mean there's 60,000
people in the prison system at that
point in time prisons all over Arizona's
they've expanded with the private
prisons so as much as people came out
the blue to harm me people came out the
blue to help me now Long Island he
caught wind of the beef I'd had with my
previous cellmate he was still sweating
me a bit frying batteries at me and [ __ ]
and so he decided to introduce me to
someone who could protect me
and that was to Tony's because he knew
but if I clicked up with him I might you
know it would help me on the yard so he
didn't tell me that he said look I want
you to have a game of chess with my
friend in Sioux Tony's all right cool
what's he in for he's a multiple
homicide murderer he's doing a hundred
and forty-one years he left the dead
bodies of rivals from Arizona to Alaska
he's old-school Italian mafia never harm
women or kids so if you only murdered
rival gangsters you're top of the
respect in the prison now - Tony's
worked for the Bonanno crime family on
the job by now no senior Joe Bonanno
senior was one of the longest running
ever heads of the Mafia Council and yeah
he did eventually get run out of New
York and ended up going to
in Arizona Bob yeah he died of natural
causes
so he was quite a shrewd individual and
to Tony's was taught by Charlie bats
Battaglia which was a banana lieutenant
how to whack people and dispose of the
bodies and not get caught because
Charlie bats Battaglia had whacked
people from coast to coast and he hadn't
got caught now before I could stop Long
Island going to get to Tony's cuz I'm
like [ __ ] it now thinking all right
what if I beat him at chess maybe he's
gonna know maybe I'll be next on his hit
list but before I could stop him he just
took off so I'm stood in the dayroom
crapping myself well to Tony's he's got
a lot of time I now like 20-something
years maybe folks some years it comes
down the stairs like uncle Jun about The
Sopranos
and then in a fake British accent he put
you saw it he sees I'm nervous and he
puts me at easy girls have you ever had
bloody tea and crumpets with the Beatles
bloody hot bloody tea crumpets yeah so I
play chess with him I beat him quite
fast and at the end of the game he said
how come you beat me so fast I said
because you kept speaking your mind
throughout the game you wouldn't show
someone your hand in a game of cards
with you and he slaps his hand he goes
Oh me and my big mouth I didn't know he
was testing me Long Island I told him I
was a writer and I had a blog John Jill
journal and to charli's was looking for
someone to write his life story mm-hmm
so he said look Shawn to stay alive on
the road of life I've had to become a
quick judge of character I like you I
think you know this guy would you be
willing to write my life story I said
yeah I won't be honored now I wasn't
supposed to go on his cell bought cell
visiting is prohibited but he had people
stationed outside watching for guards
and I mean he sell now for months on end
every single day right in his life story
down as a book and by the end of it he
said that he felt like I was the son
that you never had and when we were out
the fence saying goodbye just
I was about to get released by that time
I was in minimum security came to the
fence to say goodbye both of our eyes
were missing over and we had that's such
a powerful bond now sadly to Tony's died
in 2010 from liver cancer from his own
drug taking so he didn't get to see the
publication of his book which is called
the mafia philosopher to town Reese
which is available worldwide and it was
only funny when he was a joke
[Laughter]